[Music]
Bronx New York 1973 the birthplace of
hip-hop a young man named Clive Campbell
better known as DJ Cool hurt got the
movement started and people dancing at a
back to school party
playing break beats or instrumental
Snippets of songs and a continuous loop
on two turntables it was right here on
Sedgwick Avenue in the Bronx and this
ordinary looking apartment building
where a party full of teenagers helped
launch a new music style now known the
world over as hip hop
perk and later other prominent DJs gave
others a window into life in the Bronx
we created something from nothing living
in the Bronx it was like Beirut all the
buildings were abandoned we were trying
to get away from the everyday things
that was happening like a single parent
homes or gang activity drugs we got to
do something just to just to take our
minds off of of everything that's going
on and stuff like Theodore Livingston
AKA Grand wizard Theodore developed the
technique known as scratching
using Funk Soul Jazz and rock Classics
they created an entirely new sound and
what has since become a multi-billion
dollar industry they use it
for social justice they use it for
political movements they use it for
profits become entrepreneurs whether
fashion designers or you know production
music producers or even
today hip-hop is in film television
advertising the universal hip-hop Museum
currently under construction seeks seek
serve the movement's roots in resonance
around the round the globe it's the
voice of the voiceless no matter where
you from
New York has been hosting Live Events
all month to Mark the 50th anniversary
of hip-hop many of the movement's
biggest stars are coming back to perform
culminating with a star-studded lineup
in the neighborhood Where it All Began
Kristen salumi Al Jazeera the Bronx